the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic hey I'd like to welcome
everybody to this episode of the arthur
c clarke center for human imaginations
into the impossible podcast i am you're
a fearful host Bryan Keating joining me
today is one of my favorite authors
science journalist skulls hello Sarah
and thanks for having me it's great to
have you on the into the impossible
podcast today we'll be discussing your
brand new book which is your second book
I believe and it is called there they
are already here about why there is this
frequently reported description of
flying saucers and and why that may be
and what that tells us about the state
of the world and how people perceive
interesting phenomena such as
unidentified flying objects so Sarah I
have to say your last book making
contact was a was a biography of Jill
tarter and and the realm of kind of a
investigative journalism so to speak but
also pursuing this ambitious goal of
perhaps hearing and listening to perhaps
extraterrestrial intelligence and now
you're writing a book are you written a
book a wonderful book about seeing
flying saucers unidentified flying
objects and various locations around the
world and my next question for you is
what is next for you is it a book about
Yeti or the Loch Ness monster I don't
know I feel like other other writers
kind of have the cryptids and the
cryptozoology pretty well covered I'm
actually I've actually been doing some
research into the history of doomsday
cults lately now that we're in this
strange state of the world so I don't
know if that will turn into anything not
but I have a batch of books to read
about it so we'll see what happens
no maybe they'll bring you down to San
Diego where we've had our fair share of
cults some unfortunately successful in
their pursuit of their own personal
Doomsday's but I can't can't wait to
learn more about that project for you so
I want to talk
begin the book discussion of they are
already here and will have not only a
you know a screenshot from the book's
cover and some images that you provided
us but also we'll have a giveaway for
listeners on the iTunes Store to the
actual audio version of the podcast give
away a copy months the bookstores get
liberated from lock down we are
currently and Co vid lock down I want to
talk about the book the process of
writing the book and of course you know
hopefully entice our listeners or
audience to go and pick up a copy but I
want to ask first after writing making
contact
what impelled you to want to write this
book and sort of sort of Seti adjacent
in the sense so what what when I'm told
you did to want to write they are
already here yeah actually when I
finished making contact I didn't intend
to write any other books and definitely
not any more books about aliens or alien
adjacent things that was kind of
unexpected but it all started when there
was a New York Times story that came out
in late 2017 that was all about this
Pentagon research program that
supposedly had done a bunch of work
trying to figure out what UFOs are or as
the military likes to call them UAP an
identified aerial phenomena because it
sounds more serious and I was very
interested in this story as someone who
had done a bunch of research on study
and had kind of covered the the space
industry for a while and I just started
setting out trying to confirm or deny
all the things that were in this story
about about this UFO research program
and in doing that any time as you know
as a scientist or a journalist when you
go out to research something you meet a
bunch of people who have been
researching it for much longer than you
and who know a lot more than you do and
it was what I meant those people who had
been really interested in UFOs for years
or decades that I discovered that UFO
people as I sometimes call them are
just all you know conspiracy theorists
coups there's a lot of very smart good
researchers out there who just happened
to have this as their subject and then I
started to think you know why and what
place do UFOs hold in our culture
because there's this really persistent
phenomenon and that's too long for one
article so I had to go off and write a
book oh you are very renowned a
journalist and in fact we met several
years ago you did a story about one of
the research projects I was involved
with and to look for peculiar phenomenon
known as cosmic birefringence and twists
and certain properties of the light that
comes from the earliest times in the
cosmos and that kind of segues into you
know my first set of you know questions
as a professional astronomer you know
does observations including some
conducted with large radio telescopes
such as the ones behind me and my screen
virtual background from the Very Large
Array out in Socorro New Mexico we use
these massive telescopes and you know
basically any night of the year for a
radio telescope is almost as good as
perfectly pristine clear crisp night
that you described in the book having
experienced the 2017 eclipse of the Sun
and then encountering an unidentified
flying object I want to first you know
kind of beam this conversation around
the very weighty and important issues
that you bring up in this book of
confirmation bias and sort of you know
the the notion that we sometimes see
what we want to see but I want to begin
with the question that some of my
astronomer friends want me to ask you
which is you know given that we have you
know thousands of telescopes radio
microwave and and optical telescopes
flying the skies looking for any shred
of evidence over the last you know 50
hundred years where the SETI kind of not
not just study but the notion of
extraterrestrials perhaps visiting this
planet how come we tend not to see them
in it from coming from professional
astronomers in your opinion yeah well I
think the first and probably easiest
answer to that question is that
astronomers tend to be more from
earlier with what they see in the sky if
somebody who is looking at data from a
telescope all the time
sees something anomalous either trains
to you know try try very hard to figure
out what it is and not just say that's a
crazy thing and I don't understand it
but to go out and try to understand it
and then also are familiar with things
like you know you get a lot of people
just casual observers who will see
things like Venus which can look very
strange in the sky and think that's the
UFO but an astronomer would think that
looks like it's in the part of the sky
where Venus is and in terms of you know
telescopes I think that that is a good
question why we have all of this hard
data not just from astronomical
observatories but also from space-based
observatories that are doing earth
observation that could theoretically see
some sign of alien presence on earth and
why they why they don't charge we know
and I think that's a problem for the UFO
communities which we have all of these
sensors why we don't have any hard data
and what we have instead are just a
bunch of eyewitness reports and I think
especially physical scientists are
rightly very skeptical of of eyewitness
reports and I know I know personally I
mean I'm not a scientist I'm a
journalist but when especially prior to
this book if I saw something I didn't
understand in the sky like it wouldn't
have a deep effect on me I don't think
really in the way that it does for a lot
of people I would just see it and think
that's weird I don't understand what
that is but probably someone could and I
think a lot of people without scientific
training especially think then that if
they don't understand it then therefore
it must be not understand Apple which is
just a difference in the different
thinking yeah so one thing that we are
both connected to is being open to
evidence but not you know hopefully not
being prejudiced by the desire to
leave something for example and that's a
blicket you know it's not discussed in
the past and in many different regimes
whether it be in science when we want to
make a big discovery for different
reasons personal professional prestige
that that sometimes influences decisions
that in ways that aren't intrinsically
scientific and you go through the book
and you talk a little bit about you know
one of the most foremost kind of popular
culture references to the to the
phenomenon of of UFO isn't that is of
course the X photos and the theme or
sort of the tagline of the x-files and
all these posters is I want to believe
and I usually get asked this question of
you scientists you know what do I hope
to see and what do I want to come out of
a given project and it's a very delicate
question because on one hand you can't
help but you know have a desire we're
only human after all we're humans doing
science even despite the kind of cliches
to the contrary but what do you make of
this desire that for some of these it's
hard enough for someone who is a
scientist to keep his or her
confirmation bias out of the out of the
mixture but how do you what do you make
of it for people that are you know may
be prone to believing in conspiracies
whatever that means and and or you know
perhaps cover-ups by more powerful
agencies what is it about the human
brain that really seeks to observe or
discern these phenomena yeah I think I
mean anytime you go into a topic and you
already know what you want to find which
like like you said it flicks all of us
no matter how objectives we try to be
that can't help but affect your thinking
and you know the scientific process has
some built-in checks and balances
against that at least at least in some
places but if you're a person who let's
say you you want to believe in UFOs like
Mulder on the x-files then when you do
see Venus on the the skyline or
something else is going in one thing to
see something
then chances are you you're more likely
to interpret it as something strange
because that supports this view that you
already had and I think probably most of
us are prone to that in some ways and
that but then you can stop yourself and
say I just think that because that's
what I want to think but that's I think
that's kind of a little bit against our
natural nature so it takes an extra kind
of metacognitive step also this
additional element that that a lot of
the UO anthropology type of a talk to
pointed out which is that's you know
movies and TV and books that x-files you
know everything that's about UFOs or
alien that's on earth has trained us
from from the time that we started
consuming media to think that when we
see something weird in the sky it must
be an alien spaceship because that was
what was in Independence Day and the
x-files and basically anything else and
if we didn't come into it with that
interpretation you know we might think
of it as something else like maybe if we
grew up in a culture where we were or
all the movies were about weird
atmospheric phenomena would be like wow
look at that weird atmospheric
phenomenon and this is we thought we
come into it with all these cultural
biases built in that it's hard to even
recognize this by issues because they're
so they're the water that we schlemm in
yeah that's one of the things that that
I noted in reading your book and talking
with friends and family about it is that
it's really kind of a stealth psychology
book it's really written in a
perspective that you really have to
examine yourself as John Muir you know
one of the foremost naturalist in
history described you know his voyage
into nature as more going you know going
out as he went out he went in and the
way that he found himself is really by
looking and by going out into the wild
I'll get that put it in the show notes
but the point is that that the book has
has a real
wonderful quality about it this is gamma
TARDIS aerosol skulls about her book
they are already here why people see
saucers and this is really highlighted
in a way that surprised me one you know
I'm of course familiar with standard
sort of perceptions of lay people and
even scientists that are kind of
anti-government and even
anti-authoritarian about what what
surprised me is that the general public
thinks of us you know we astronomers as
a sort of the man you know this this
culture of authority and you describe
you know kind of these these government
installations that are really
astronomical facilities and I wonder if
you take the listeners through that that
journey to the various you know major
telescope facilities you yourself have
worked at one in your previous life and
career and then at some part small part
led to of course making contact and
writing right now authoritative
biography of Jill tarter
and the French are there so can you talk
about why why isn't that surprised you
that people kind of perceive even
astronomers as part of perhaps a you
know a cabal maliciousness yeah I think
there is definitely a certain subset of
people who do whether it's like the far
end of things of you know Flat Earth
believers thinking that astronomers are
manipulating data to show a circular
earth and faking the orbits of things
from space or people who think that
there's somebody at NASA manipulating
images from you know the Mars rovers to
remove the alien so that we don't see
them and that is the theory that exists
and what I have found partly from yet
like you mentioned I used to work at
Green Bank Observatory which is a radio
telescope and in West Virginia and I my
job there was interacting with the
public a lot and I was surprised to
learn when I worked there that lots of
people you know probably one on every
other tour thought that we had some
secret evidence of aliens that we just
weren't telling them about and AI was
like they definitely wouldn't tell me
because I would tell everyone
and be like in general astronomers are
hiding things because the culture of
science is to you know produce produce
open data and do things in public and
make things transparent but I think what
I found from from working in Green Bank
and visiting various other spots
including one that I do right now the
Very Large Array is that you know to a
lot of people astronomy is really opaque
professions use and astronomical words
like people might read stories about you
know cosmic discoveries but they don't
really understand exactly how it happens
or what it is these telescopes are doing
especially ones like radio telescopes
where they don't produce traditional you
know visual images visible light images
that you can see and so that's that's
one thing so when something is opaque
people just kind of put their own
interpretation on it sometimes and then
there's also the elements that a lot of
scientific facilities have started their
lives as military facilities or with
some kind of military funding in their
passion now with the internet it's not
hard for people to find that out and
then kind of springboard that into the
present and say well they're still doing
secret government work and and things
like that and just to see all of these
invisible hands in the background kind
of moving the pieces and yeah I don't I
don't think of astronomers as the men
but I can definitely understand why some
people might well you know another
aspect that comes through a little bit
more in making contact than then in they
are already here is kind of this
adversarial nature of science in that
you know there's nothing more that I
would like to do than to you know make
make a discovery but there's in a second
to that in many scientist Minds is it's
almost disproving someone else's
discovery because that's the real nature
of scientific confirmation is that it
must be confirmed it must be replicated
in an independent reproducible
Jim yeah we always refer to this you
know as peer review etc and despite you
know so my colleagues have the poster in
their offices I have no peers but but
you know for most of us we certainly
have peers and superiors but the
question of you know if somebody were to
see something you know there'd be
nothing you know more more you know kind
of significant in the astronomers career
than to actually make a discovery and I
wonder does the UFO culture even
recognize that that that having you know
peer review of the equivalent of a peer
review or some kind of crowdsourcing of
the of data of observations could
benefit the credulity that people have
in greater society yeah I think there's
definitely certain elements of the
people who are interested in UFOs who
would welcome that kind of thing and
there have been different attempts to
try to do that like there's an
organization called MUFON the mutual UFO
network that has kind of tried to
standardize investigation and you know
produce reports they're not peer
reviewed but they're trying to have some
kind of reproducible procedure but a
hard thing about that and like we were
talking about earlier is that lots of
the data that exists right now that
people are trying to dig into is
first-person accounts which we all know
we're not very reliable no matter who
you are like if I have an account you
shouldn't trust it
and I think you know there there are
people people do advocate for our
attempts to get to get hard data and do
peer review and in but the UFO culture
in general is not as open as scientists
I like there's there's one guy named
Robert Bigelow who has funded a number
of UFO studies that we're supposed to
collect this hard data with you know
sensors and cameras and spreadsheets and
and you know software and scientific
types things and that data for whatever
reason I'm not sure it never became
public and never about public
should a peer review journal and so I
think in a lot of cases that's probably
related to that I want to believe
phenomenons that people are finding data
that doesn't align with their hypothesis
and when that happens you don't want to
publish it which happens to scientists
sometimes you who don't publish there no
results or things like that but I think
it's more prevalent in the UFO community
yeah so what it's speaking of Bigelow I
want to kind of address that particular
elephant in the room and kind of wonder
you know what is it about rich mostly
men that seem to be so drawn to this or
a prominent man versus when or did you
is it is it true I mean are there would
you say what would you say that gender
no kind of breakdown is yeah it is
heavily male the general demographic
yeah I think I mean I'm making contact
of course you know one of the lead you
know characters in the sense is Paul
Allen of Microsoft Fame the late Paul
Allen passed away about a year or so ago
and and Paul funded you know this
massive project of was really the
culmination of gel tartars career to set
the Institute and that you described the
trials and tribulations of that
wonderful facility but it kind of lit
yet to live up to to the promise that it
could have had but I wonder what is it
about these you know billionaires that
make them so intrigued about about
investigation of you know potentially
fringe or you know at least outside the
scientific mainstream and in some cases
for UFOs in particular maybe less so for
SETI I think we'll get to you know the
status of settiing a little bit but what
do you think it appeals to them about
this about you know using their wealth
to look for things like UFOs I'm talking
about
em and the blink-182
co-leader Tom DeLonge he had come talk
yeah and his ad astra project can you
maybe speculate and what makes people
devote so many other resources to this
pursuit yeah I can absolutely with the
caveat that it's expecting
and pop psychology um I think in my mind
what motivates people is this similar to
what you were just talking about with
scientists where there's nothing more
appealing than making a really big
discovery in that is a big motivating
factor and why people are doing science
or researching UFOs in the first place
because as fringe as we think of this
topic as and it is fringe if someone you
know did find a flying saucer and verify
that it came from outer space that would
be a very large that would be huge and I
think is that people with a lot of money
who have the resources to pursue
something huge and can also just risk
losing all of that money are willing to
do it for the it's a low probability
high consequence event I guess and when
you get to a certain place with your
money and then also with your reputation
like people still respected Powell and
after he funded a search for broadcast
from extraterrestrials I'm not sure how
but how much respect people have for Tom
DeLonge or but Reno Robert Bigelow as a
businessman who well actually his
company recently shut down for a while
due to due to the pandemics but he had a
module attached to the space station the
key lifted NASA contractor taken
seriously and yet ran like a Paranormal
Research Institute and I think once you
get to a certain threshold you can kind
of do what you want and people will say
like that the quirky guy but they'll
still take you seriously yeah I think
that is interesting you know I also
again pure speculation psychological
armchair analysis is worth what you pay
for it but you know this legacy of one
thing you know somebody said recently
you know once most people about Jeff
Bezos and you know once they get to be a
certain level of wealth they really just
want to live forever and in some sense
you know making a discovery like this
would be you know scientifically in
scientific immortality if you will so
maybe that's a part of it as well one
person no I've always been very into
as Michael Shermer and hopefully you
guys will connect together too and
Michael of course describes an alien
abduction that happened to him in his
book as well as this wonderful book
called mistakes were made but not by me
by Calif Carol Chalmers
I don't know if you've read that book
before yeah that's really good but it's
it's about all sorts of cognitive
dissonance and how human beings cannot
tolerate being in the state of this
dissonance and extraordinary links that
police officers go to justify to
themselves that the you know that the
perpetrator is guilty and and how'd you
know attorneys will do similar things
and even in marriage or relationships
that people will have kind of blinders
on while they're in the you know
pre-nuptial you know kind of phase and
then they all of a sudden our eyes are
open them and the part I haven't
complete I'm almost three-quarters of
the way done but but basically I believe
that there's a virtue in teaching these
kinds of dissonance and biases in the
guarding against them at a young age as
well as possible and I think you know
Michael's adventure when he was abducted
by aliens or he believed that he was
really led him into a new career which
is quite the opposite a 180 degree
opposite towards the realm of debunking
and being a skeptic which held hopefully
as I said have you on his show and you
know we've discussed this he and I
together just this adversarial nature
that scientists have and you know
whether or not it's it's a good thing I
think you know all fields all fields
need sort of a beginning phase where
they sort of get get their start and and
to take it seriously I think things like
said II have been have been going on now
for 60 years actually I think this is
the 60th year of the original papers
that will produce in the project Ozma
and you talked a little bit about that
in this book did you find you know kind
of old friends and recurring themes
coming from making contact in the making
of they're already here
yeah there's not so much overlap exactly
with the people researching study and
the people researching UFOs but of
course the people who are doing study
get a lot of emails and random phone
calls from people who are interested in
UFOs and want a respected astronomer to
be able to explain that to them but one
one overlap I did find what was one that
articulated by a radio star on her name
astronomer named Garrett Mercer who once
once was involved in SETI and it's in
its earlier years and then came to see
the motivation behind it as almost
religious like even if SETI astronomers
as you know I go into this without a
hypothesis I am trying to find out
whether there is intelligent life
elsewhere and I'm just trying to figure
that out he pointed out that is it it
has to be motivated by the hope that
it's out there and also a lot of the
justification for doing SETI is about
you know things like if we find a
civilization they've existed for a long
time therefore they must be peaceful
because they haven't you know atom bombs
each other to death or they've figured
out how to solve their own global
warming and so it kind of has this
salvation thing going on and I think
both of those we which said the
astronomers would probably argue with do
have some amount of overlap with with
UFO believers who kind of look to the
skies for us for something more powerful
and they wouldn't call it a God but it
kind of plays that that role for them
and I think that's he called it the
salvation school of study I want to get
into that towards the end in a few
minutes when we talk a little bit about
the kind of personal motivation and
perhaps revelations that you've had in
the writing of this book before we get
there we have an event earlier this year
at the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination which
he called is et already lurking in our
own cosmic backyard with scientists and
authors both of them
Jim Benford and Paul Davies and Paul
Davies wrote a book in 2010 so exactly
ten years ago called the eerie silence
and in that case he makes the in that
book he makes a very convincing case
that that the likelihood that the
extraterrestrials could have really
overcome some of these great giant
hurdles to their existence to become not
only as Jill tarter often points out
it's not enough that you create life you
know slime mold on on Enceladus is very
fascinating and important but it has no
technological capabilities another handy
pointed out you know perhaps it could be
that there could already be here create
priests you know empting your title that
aliens could be here but in the form of
sort of a shadow biosphere and I wonder
did you consider you know not just the
saucer appearance I mean from you UFOs
that's by nature but but of aliens among
us but not in the kind of prosthetic
forehead type variety that we typically
see detected yeah it's yeah I didn't
include it in the research that I have
looked into the shadow biosphere idea
that life are either arose twice here or
you know came here from somewhere else
and still exists and I think that's I
think that's an intriguing possibility
and I think there's a there's a very
smart people who have written about ways
to look for life as you don't already
know it and that seems to be the problem
with fighting like a shadow biosphere
here on earth is how do you how do you
look for something when you don't know
what it is and how do you differentiate
it from this life and from not life and
it's it's an intriguing and intriguing
topic and but in in the research for
they are already here the for my most
encountered it
was more like the their reptilians and
Congress kind of form which is different
how much shadow biosphere so I like to
conclude this wonderful discussion by
asking questions that are tangentially
related to the topic we were just
discussing at least at first and that
has to do with with reading and books
and how you know in my mind
second only to DNA which you know
perhaps some alien microbe might have in
a slightly different form than we
experience here on earth but you know
what do books mean to you this is your
second book which is a heroic
accomplishment by by anyone's standards
but I I wonder you know what do books
mean to you and in the case of you know
the future legacy that a book can
provide I always like to ask my author
guests if you would rather prefer that
you have a hundred readers one year from
now for one reader a hundred years from
now hmm that is a hard question
[Music]
I think I think I would prefer at least
for this most recent work a hundred
readers now because I feel like not just
muttons for sales purposes but I feel
like this I undertook this book based on
something that happened just a few years
ago and it's kind of reflecting on where
we are now as a society and how UFO
belief rises and falls with what's with
what's happening culturally and I feel
like maybe especially while we're all
isolated in our own houses in it in a
kind of moment of fear and uncertainty
which is something I talked a lot about
in the book that maybe this would have
some resonance beyond just UFO people
but I think for the book about Jill
tarter I might prefer one reader a
hundred years from now because when I
was but I was working on that book I
thought a lot about what what if that he
succeeds someday and we find something
and someone wants to look back on what
the endeavor was like in its early years
and the people who started it and like I
can create something now that someone in
the future could have as a as a present
record while all of the players are you
know alive and still doing things to us
now
but to me books you know I read a ton
certainly very early I was obsessed with
books I would go on car trips with my
family and my mom would always be
telling me to look out the window with
the nice things that the world that they
were showing me because I always had my
nose buried in a book but I think then
and now you know is a wave to go places
that you can't go which is pretty cool
right now and also a way to get
different perspectives on things you
know there's some studies about fiction
reading and empathy and have people who
read fiction especially have more of it
because you just force to think about
the minds of other of other characters
and
yeah so that's that is I think what I
look to them okay and speaking of those
readers now my next of the second of the
5 questions that I like to ask authors
is of those readers those hundred
thousand readers that you're hopefully
gonna get thanks to this podcast and and
you know how we're going to advertise it
on the surface of the Moon for those
hundred readers thousand meters however
many you get of those who which sort of
would you prefer as your target audience
people that are skeptical about this
phenomenon or people that are you know
sort of already down and they they sort
of already are predisposed to the notion
that UFOs exist
hmm I think I think I would prefer the
people who are predisposed to thinking
UFOs exist because I think it's always
useful to be able to see from the
outside something that you're a part of
a see has somebody else views it and
because I think UFOs you know whatever
they are to people no matter what they
think of them the seeing of them is a
human phenomenon and when you're part of
it part of a like a culture it's hard
it's hard to see its its flaws and it's
good parts and I don't I think it's
people help you from the outside
somebody you know continuing on that on
that theme one question I'd like to ask
especially people that are
astronomically inclined is a quote that
I read include in my book I saw Ron
kirkegaard
who said that life can only be
understood backwards but must be lived
forwards I think it's this kind of you
know typifies astronomy always looking
back into space and and seeing things as
they were in the past so I'm wondering
if you could look back into your past
and the book is very remarkable to me
because it's also very personal it talks
about you as a person and now that you
you know established your your credit
your credentials that's right there are
many articles and book and your previous
book now I think you know you're giving
the public your audience some more
insight into who you are so I'm curious
as to you know what do you think you
would look back and tell your 20 year
old self that it might seem impossible
at the time but but looking forward it
will work out and and and that kind of
goes along with the theme of this
podcast into the impossible with Sir
Arthur C Clark's second law as first
being any sufficiently advanced society
is indistinguishable from magic and the
second one is the only way to find out
what is possible is to go a little bit
out of your comfort zone into the
impossible so you could tell 20-year old
Sarah sculls a little bit of advice what
would that be yeah I mean I guess I
think related to the the parts of my
past that are in the book when I was
when I was 20 years old I was recently
out of I had grown up a very devout
religious person my family was more than
I'd recently left at that point I was um
you know skeptical and kind of I can't
think of a word other than demeaning of
other people's beliefs just because I
found any kind of belief so like a
nassima to this newly very very
skeptical of a very a theist point at
which I found myself and in kind of a
book like this where I'm examining other
people's beliefs it forces you to you
know give them respect and try to
understand them and not just be like
well I was more than I'm not so I know
you and so I think I think I would tell
myself like just um you know you don't
you don't know everything and maybe take
a little more time to understand other
people which is probably something most
20 year olds could hear more often but I
think it's right yeah you describe your
encounters at area 51 summers now kind
of being the elder stateswoman in the
group and its kind of delightful to hear
the journey that you go on and the
candor that you exhibited I always like
that people are honest about their and
really portray yeah you're not a side
as you said but you write a lot about
scientific topics and and I think you
know to to show that we are you know we
nom-nom non-scientist show non
scientists that we are human wonderful
service that you continue to provide
last question is about curiosity and
imagination here at the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination i'm always
curious what my guests have to say about
their particular skillset and maybe it's
a set of skills you're a public speaker
you do journalism you do scientific
research into your subjects at least
even kind of large large scale game but
what you do cannot be taught can you
actually communicate teach is a part
partially you know born into who you are
and your life experiences and so maybe
it won't be able to be taught what are
your thoughts about the transmedia of
your values and of your of your skill
set I mean I think it's probably true
that people are born and then it
engrained through nurture with different
levels of curiosity and engagement with
the world and with the people in it
which I I know that I mean as a
journalist people that people think of
you as mostly being a writer but mostly
my job is actually talking to people not
writing about them that's it and doing
research and I think that you can teach
that in the same way that you can teach
yourself to be aware of your own
cognitive biases I think you can teach
yourself to be curious about people and
curious about their stories and curious
about how that's all interacting with
the world around you and I think I mean
especially even looking for stories when
I first started doing journalism I think
I saw it you know there how will I ever
find in that stories and Minnis as soon
as you start to think of you know
everything you encounter as an open
question that you can go investigate and
that's the way you start to see the
whole world and so um I think if you
just take a step and take a step back
and note
what your mind kind of maybe wanders
about for one second and then instead of
wondering about it for one second just
like dwell and a little a little more
and talk to people about it and i think
i think that's translatable wonderful
thank you so much all right the last
question is really the part of the plug
zone not the twilight zone but the plug
zone so where can people connect to you
online social media etc sure I'm Twitter
I am skull sarah SC o le SS AR h and i
have a website where i put up all of my
articles which is www.osho.com/copyright
osho is also thank you so much it's been
a real treat i wish you the greatest
success with the book and I hope that
you'll keep in touch yes definitely and
thanks for having me
[Music]
you sure about the future is it will be
absolutely
[Music]